It's great to welcome back to the program
today, Dr. Isaac Veau Ghosh, who's an infectious
disease physician and scientist based at the
University of Toronto and Toronto General
Hospital.
Great to have you back on.
Thanks for having me back.
So we spoke recently, but everything has changed
since we spoke.
I mean, the degree to which this has has continued
to spread as someone who works in this field.
Are you surprised by the trajectory since
we've spoken?
Sadly, no.
We knew that this was going to spread around
the world.
We knew that countries that were reporting
cases were going to have a growing burden
of cases.
And then we knew that countries that didn't
yet have cases, we're going to start to see
they were going to start to see cases very
shortly.
And, you know, we take a step back and look
at the 30000 foot view.
Now, you know, most of the world is affected
and sadly, some places are more severely affected
than others.
So let's start there.
I have a bunch of questions, including from
my audience.
I'm not going through them in order of importance,
but just to start somewhere, we're seeing
very different death rates in different countries.
And a lot of ideas have been posited that
there's two different strains of different
lethality, although I've not seen good evidence
for that so far that the populations are older
or sicker in some places.
What do we know so far about the drastically
differing death rates?
Yeah.
So short answer is that I you know, we don't
know as a medical and scientific community,
but we have lots of different theories.
And I think this will be fascinating when
the dust settles and, you know, a year or
two from now we have better answers.
So I still think we have to remain humble
that we don't have all the answers.
Having said that, I think there's several
factors that come into play here.
This business of having several strains of
the virus, I'm not entirely sure that's going
to play out.
I don't think that's going to pan out in the
end.
Viruses mutate all the time.
It doesn't necessarily mean that it's more
virulent or more deadly than another virus.
And there's likely multiple strains of this
virus as it spreads through different continents.
It doesn't necessarily mean that those viruses
will cause different severity of illness.
So that's one point.
The second point is we know that the populations
that this virus is affecting are different.
And we definitely know that this virus has
more severe outcomes in people who are over
the age of 60 and especially in those over
the age of 80.
So elderly populations, unfortunately, are
getting significantly impacted by this infection.
And we've seen, you know, for example, places
like Italy where there is tremendous sadly,
this tremendous death toll and this is vastly
overrepresented in elderly people.
And I think the third major factor here is
how robust the health care system is and how
robust a public health system is within a
country.
And we've seen countries, for example, like
South Korea, Singapore, Hong Kong, Taiwan,
where they have fantastic clinical abilities
and clinical capabilities and also a very
robust public health system.
And they really implemented strong control
initiatives earlier on in the epidemic.
And and most of those countries, I mean, everyone's
coming out battered and bruised, but they're
coming out less battered and bruised compared
to most others.
So to follow up on on some of the discrepancies
that we're seeing before we move on to testing
early, the data from China suggested a significantly
higher death rate for men than women.
And it was suggested that for cultural reasons,
men are more likely to smoke in China and
that that might be the explanation.
But it looks like that discrepancy is persisting
in other countries without the cultural smoking
differences.
What what do we know about that so far?
You know, it's unclear yet, and I don't have
a good answer for that yet.
And that is obviously one of the top questions
is what are the actual risk factors for having
a serious infection and death?
We already know that age is a risk factor
and that medical co-morbidities are a risk
factor.
You know, if you're if you're sick to begin
with and you get this infection, you're more
likely to have a more serious infection and
sadly more likely to succumb to this infection.
But sex and gender are still unclear as to
how that really manifests with this infection.
And by virtue of being a male.
Is that also reflective of having a greater,
you know, depending on the country, a greater
probability of having hypertension, diabetes,
smoking?
Or is there just something about being male
that puts puts one at greater risk of having
a more severe outcome?
It's not it's not yet clear.
So let's talk a little bit about testing.
We know that here in the United States, we
have been drastically under testing.
So no surprise as more tests.
Rolls out the number of cases start to increase
dramatically, but probably still drastically
under representing the real number of cases,
we are hearing from some governments that
there's really no reason to test people without
symptoms.
There's no reason to test people who are not
serious enough to be in the hospital.
I want to hear your thought about that in
general.
But then also more specifically.
Most of the tests in the US are not antibody
tests, which wouldn't tell us if someone has
had and has recovered from the disease.
Would the issue of testing everybody be different
if we were using an antibody test rather than
a pathogen test?
OK, so there's several excellent components
of that question that I think need to be addressed.
The first component is the degree of testing,
and I agree with you completely.
There is tremendous under testing, not only
in the United States, but actually in most
parts of the world.
So the actual figures that we see, the numbers
that are reported are gross underestimates
of the true burden of infection in just about
anywhere in the world.
Now, some places have more access to diagnostic
tests than others.
For example, if we compare the United States
with South Korea, the United States is testing
relatively fewer people, significantly fewer
people compared to a place like South Korea.
So, you know, we still so South Korea's numbers
are probably more of an accurate reflection
of the true burden of this disease in that
country relative to the numbers coming out
of the United States.
But we get it.
We all know that.
And, you know, there's various reasons for
why some countries have imposed broader diagnostic
testing than others in the United States.
Again, these are completely a political statement,
but there was just some incredible bureaucratic,
logistic and economic hurdles that got in
the way and that continue to get in the way
of providing wide diagnostic testing.
And that certainly has set the United States
back in their fight against the Cauvin 19
pandemic.
And it's really unfortunate to watch that
unfold in real time.
But by no means are other countries perfect.
There's many, many reasons why places just
just have not tested broadly.
The next point I think that's important to
address is the utility of the test that we're
doing.
And I think we have to be mindful of the question
we're asking in a clinical sense.
One of the questions we ask is, do you have
this infection?
Yes or no?
Because that is going to impact our clinical
manage and management of that individual now
and also in the coming days.
So the testing that's being done now, which
is which is a PCR test, which basically answers
that question, is that virus present in you?
Yes or no?
Are you infected?
That's an extremely important test.
And that's the appropriate test to be doing
right now.
And it's you know, it's not the most comfortable
test to do what's called a nasal pharyngeal
swab, where they take a big swab and they
stick it all the way into the back of your
nose.
People think it just like a little thing in
the front of their nose.
No.
Anyone that's had this knows that it's not
the most comfortable test to have, but you've
got to get a good sample.
And that's the way to do it.
And that's the appropriate has to be doing,
because that answered the question, yes or
no?
Am I infected with this virus?
And that will impact clinical management of
that individual now and also in the foreseeable
days, days ahead.
What you're referring to as well is what's
called an antibody test, which basically asks
the question, have you ever been infected
with this virus?
Yes or no?
It doesn't tell you.
Are you currently infected with this virus?
It's.
Have I ever been infected with this virus?
Yes or no?
Antibody tests or typically blood tests.
And there are many groups that are developing
these antibody tests to determine if someone
has ever had an exposure to this particular
corona virus.
Yes or no?
These tests are hard to develop because as
you can imagine, there's lots of different
types of corona viruses.
We have the common cold, which has there's
four different types of corona viruses that
are implicated in the common cold.
Plus, we have this covered 19 pandemic.
And, you know, we've heard about birds and
stars and other corona viruses as well.
So one of the issues is, is there cross reactivity
when we're looking for this specific corona
virus versus other common corona viruses that
cause the common cold?
You know, I think there's a lot of research
teams that are developing these serologic
tests.
These are excellent tests to have.
I think at the end of the day, we'll be very,
very valuable to use those tests widely to
see truly what proportion of the population
was affected by this COBA 19 pandemic.
But, you know, in terms of clinical management.
Right now, I don't think the serology tests
would be nearly as useful as the PCR test
that we're doing right now.
Yeah, I mean, I guess we're we're my we're
I'm thinking about it would be.
Imagine that you tested large portions of
the population and found that, you know, imagine
it's one and a half or two percent of the
population had the antibodies.
Would that be useful from an infectious disease
perspective?
In thinking about the trajectory, so to speak?
Yes, absolutely.
So I just want to distinguish two sort of
overlapping Venn diagrams of clinical care
and public health.
And of course, these overlaps significantly.
But from a clinical standpoint, that antibody
test may be a little bit helpful, but the
PCR test would be extraordinarily helpful.
It's also available, you know, in decent labs.
It can be available in a matter of hours.
So the PCR test is valuable from that standpoint.
But when we're looking at, you know, populations
and, you know, as you point out, if we knew
that one population had much greater exposure
to this virus compared to other populations.
Yeah, it's also extremely valuable from a
public health standpoint because that can
help drive policy, that could help guide public
health policy, that could drive, you know,
vaccine efforts when a vaccine is available.
That could also drive more local public health
initiatives such as the physical or social
distancing measures that we're all talking
about and employing widely these days.
So, you know, it's certainly valuable information,
but I think from a public health standpoint,
the serology test would be more valuable at
this point in time.
And from a clinical standpoint, the PCR is
a little bit more valuable.
We're gonna go to a break on our TV and radio
show and podcast with Dr. Isaac Ghosh put
we'll continue talking on our YouTube channel
where you can find the remainder of our conversation.
So then we get into the social distancing
methods and the questions that are that are
now coming up about should you go get groceries
or have them delivered?
And how do you weigh or manage the exposure
of being in a grocery store versus someone
you don't know touching your fruits and vegetables
in this type of thing?
At what degree at what level of granularity
do these decisions make an impact, so to speak?
Yeah, I mean, obviously, these are very challenging
questions because it's hard to micromanage
every potential situation that may arise.
But I think if people are mindful of the general
principles, we'll all be OK.
And the general principles are, you know,
physical distance.
I know we're talking about social distancing.
But I think it's important words do matter.
And I think we're switching to using a physical
distancing measure because social interaction
is extraordinarily important and especially
important during these very difficult times
where we are physically separated from one
another.
So when we're talking about these, you know,
physical distancing measures, I think as the
public health officials have been saying,
you know, keep it to about six feet if possible.
Of course, we can't micro regulate every potential
interaction that may happen.
Of course, people need to go out and get groceries
and, you know, fill their car with gas and,
you know, still live their lives with, you
know, as much normalcy as possible.
But, of course, we also have to abide by these
rules to ensure personal safety and also for
public safety.
So, you know, grocery stores, many grocery
stores have adapted to this as well.
And you can tell that many people are going
to grocery stores at all hours.
Some grocery stores I've seen have taken very
creative solution in the lineup.
They put tape on the floor so that they know
that people will stand in line and be separated
by an appropriate amount of space.
Many grocery stores have actually put some
hand sanitizer out.
And there's also the onus on the individual.
If you're going to go to a grocery store is
going to a public place to get essential items
that you may need, bring some hand sanitizer
if you're in touch with any high contact surfaces.
Let's be mindful of that.
Wash your hands with soap and water or use
hand sanitizer.
Be mindful about not touching your face.
And, of course, wash down any surfaces in
your home as well with, you know, the appropriate
bleach based solutions that that are that
are recommended.
So there's lots of things that we can do that
we can do that essentially mitigate our risk
of getting this infection while we practice
our physical distancing measures and simultaneously
while we go about our day to day lives and
try to care for ourselves and our families.
So last time you were on, we talked about
the question of droplet versus aerosol is
is a gradient, so to speak.
It's not just it's one or the other as that
applies to, for example, people in Boston
as the weather has been nicer.
Ah, ah, ah.
Distancing physically, but are going to parks
and bike paths, for example.
And for the most part, people know you kind
of stay separate as you pass each other.
But invariably when the bike path is three
feet wide, runners are going to pass each
other in the in the opposite direction and
they're going to be breathing as people tend
to do when when they are running.
What is the risk of an infection in these
outdoor scenarios?
I've read it's as low as 1 percent, but it's
like, what does that really mean?
Does that mean if you pass 100 people, you
infect one of them?
I mean, I think there's a few points.
One is that, you know, it's it's great to
hear that people are getting outside because
truly we're not locked in our homes.
Right.
And and, you know, these are tough times.
And, you know, if we should be encouraging,
going outside, getting fresh air, getting
exercise, but of course, still adhering to
these very important physical distancing measures.
And again, we can't micromanage every situation
that may arise.
And, you know, of course, joggers or bicyclists
might pass each other on the path.
And, you know, for the fraction of a second
that you're passing each other on the path.
You know, I think the risk of transmission
of one person is infected is like exponentially
small.
You know, this is transmitted through direct
contact or through or through droplets.
So, you know, if someone's infected and like,
there's the most unlikely of unlikely scenarios
that they're coughing as you're running or
biking by know, that would be that would be
a problem.
But I think that's a pretty unlikely scenario.
The other thing, too, is if you're sick, you
shouldn't be outside in the first place if
you're sick.
All the recommendations are stay at home and
and self isolate for a period of 14 days.
So truly, truly, if people abide by the public
health suggests not suggestions, rules, the
public health rules to to really prevent.
Mission in the community will be OK.
It's just a matter of people buying into these
ideas.
So that goes directly into the question of
the folks without symptoms or almost no symptoms.
I've seen one study that says 15 to 18 percent
of cases have no symptoms.
There's an Icelandic study that found half
had no symptoms that they could at least be
aware of.
Where are we on that?
And don't those numbers make it much more
challenging to say if you're sick, you shouldn't
be out?
Because there may be, you know, NBA players
who say, I've tested positive, but I always
felt completely fine as an example.
Yeah.
There's a few points with that.
So I think the helpful phrase is subclinical,
because if we say the term subclinical, it
really means that people are whatever they
feel, either nothing or something extraordinarily
mild.
You know, it's below the detection of the
health care system.
You're not unwell enough that you're going
to stop doing what you're doing.
to go seek medical care.
And that's the most accurate term, because
it's it's a broad umbrella term that really
captures everything under that.
The term is subclinical.
And therein lies the problem, because there
is such a large burden of subclinical infection.
There are lots of people who just don't feel
that bad, who are walking around with this
infection.
And these are individuals who are likely contributing
to the spread of this infection unknowingly
in community settings.
And this is why we have a pandemic.
This is why it's extraordinarily challenging
to control this infection and and, you know,
in the same breath.
This is why we truly need to adhere to these
physical distancing measures, because if we
truly spread apart, if we're truly mindful
about hand hygiene, if we're truly mindful
about not touching our faces, if we're truly
mindful about washing down high contact surfaces
like no door handles and elevator buttons,
we can block many of these chains of transmission.
And it's because there's so many people out
there with who are subclinical, who just have
mild to no symptoms that are that are facilitating
transmission in community settings.
We can block that by really spreading out.
The last thing I want to ask you about.
We for the last 10 or 14 days have been talking
about everything from Rim Dess here to AV.
Again, the possibility of chloroquine, whether
without a zit through Myson HIV drugs with
or without interfer on the W.H.O. is now starting
a pretty large clinical trial that doctors
all over the world are going to be able to
to opt patients into.
If you had specific thoughts about any of
these, I would love to hear them.
But more more likely, I think it would be
interesting to hear how quickly might we start
to figure out which of these is a better path
rather than a less good path and sort of what
the process will be.
Yeah.
So got an hour.
I mean, this it's fascinating.
And and it's just wonderful to hear that there
are so many potential.
We've got to be careful with our words, potential
treatment options.
And I would add that these aren't just treatment
options.
These are also being studied for prophylaxis,
meaning if potentially someone was exposed,
could they go on one of these medications
and avoid getting infected in the first place?
Now, there are well over 150 clinical trials
that are testing these various compounds.
Now, the key thing here is getting quality
data.
There's a lot of small studies that have made
huge waves.
For example, this chloroquine and the Zathura
Myson, you know, these are great tiny little
studies that are not conclusive, but what
we would call them hypothesis generating,
like, hey, maybe there's something here we
should look into this further.
But the real studies are enrolling patients
now.
And these are what we would call prospective
studies that are blinded, meaning, you know,
the people who are getting these medications
don't know which medications they're getting.
The clinicians administering the medications
don't know which medications.
Third, miss administrating.
So they're placebo controlled or blinded and
prospective studies, which is essentially
the gold standard for testing the efficacy
of various treatments.
And when we have this quality data, we will
be able to make much more meaningful suggestions
on how to treat and prevent this infection.
How long does it take?
You know, surprisingly not, as long as people
would think.
Let's put it this way.
We'll have this data available well before
a vaccine becomes available.
And these clinical trials are actively recruiting
patients.
And, you know, I would be hopeful that we
might start to see early results in the coming
six to nine weeks, because, you know, sadly,
there's no shortage of patients and these
and many of these.
Rules are actively recruiting and to have
more definitive results and probably closer
to 3 months.
So on the blinding thing, the W.H.O. trials
say they will not be blinded.
Although some of the other ones are.
Arthur Caplan from NYU said it's not ideal
for them not to be blinded.
But given the circumstances, it's still a
good trial.
What does that mean?
What what how do you balance the lack of blinding
with this sort of need to start doing this?
Yeah.
I mean, I think we should point out, too,
that there's there's so many trials that are
ongoing and each trial will have its own design
and each trial will have its inherent strengths
and its inherent weaknesses.
You know, in a perfect world, many of these
trials would be blinded, which just adds a
degree of robustness to the trial and the
competence that you have when you're stating
the results of your trial, that, you know,
there is no unintended bias from patients
or from clinicians who are administering the
trial.
That that gets bled into the trial that way.
But by no means if the trial is isn't blinded,
it doesn't mean that it wipes out the results
of the trial.
It's just, you know, it's not a perfect design.
That does not take away from the trial at
all.
And in fact, any trial, any prospective trial
is is extremely welcome at this time.
And, you know, we're gonna be hanging off
to every letter in the printed manuscripts
that come out from this.
And we're gonna be hanging off every word
of the individuals who are recruiting patients
for these trials, because we want to know,
are they working or are they not working?
And this is this is truly going to impact
the clinical management of many, many, many
patients.
Absolute last thing.
So with the chloroquine, as they throw and
trial, a lot of people, they're saying, why
an antibiotic for a virus?
My understanding is that although it is an
antibiotic, there are studies that seem to
be good, studies that show in lung cells it
functions like an antiviral.
Is that the right interpretation?
The short answer, we have no idea.
It might be.
There also may be what we would call immuno
modulate terie effects as well.
So this is very theoretical.
First of all, we don't even know if this works.
Let's be clear, that study had well, I think
what, 30 patients get with 30 a control group
like it's pretty hard to make definitive conclusions
from that study.
It's great that it was done.
It's hypothesis generating.
It's sort of like if we think about it in
volleyball terms, that's the bump.
And now we need to set and the spike.
So that's that's a very, very, very early
part.
But but like, you know, we can talk about
theoretical mechanisms.
I'm not sure it's gonna be all that helpful.
Let's see if this works or not.
With with the with the larger studies, we
will indeed.
We've been speaking with Dr. Isaac Bogot,
infectious disease physician and scientist
from the University of Toronto in Toronto
General Hospital.
Really appreciate your time once again.
Oh, thanks for having me back on